I'm Brian Kilmeade I'm at the McCallum
I'm David Asman and this is the Fox News
rundown
Wednesday April 22nd 2020
I'm Jessica Rosenthal it is still an
election year and while campaigning in
the time of coronavirus means quite a
few things have changed and there are a
lot of questions to answer about how all
of this has been handled the Trump
campaign still thinks they have the
advantage
you know Joe Biden has had some say the
benefit of staying out of the public eye
and he's been desperately searching for
relevance I'm Britt hill as America's
lockdown continues there are some out
there who believe some of the drastic
actions taken by government leaders may
be unnecessary and based on bad data it
has been clear over and over again that
the models are just completely wrong and
they've completely overstated the
hospitalizations and the ICU needs of
this and I'm Abby hornacek I've got the
final word on the Fox News rundown
this is probably not the late April the
Joe Biden or President Trump campaigns
envisioned but here we are campaigning
in the time of kovat 19 in 2020 and
things are different obviously from the
days before the pandemic we will make as
is the case for many of us campaigning
has shifted to pretty much entirely
online still fundraising is trucking
along at the end of March the Trump
campaign had raised nearly two hundred
and forty six million dollars according
to open secrets Joe Biden's campaign had
raised just over 132 million dollars
that's not counting from outside groups
interesting sidenote
at the same point in the 2016 campaign
then candidate Trump had raised only
just under fifty million dollars and
Hillary Clinton had raised 187 million
now back to this year there are no
rallies no reporters swooping in as
candidates exit a diner to ask a hard
question
no gaggles and yet the questions remain
in fact given the events so far in 2020
especially when it comes to this virus
there will be plenty of tough questions
to ask in hindsight about how all of
this was handled or not handled we know
that the president's campaign President
Trump and Brad Parr scale our campaign
manager they built the president's
reelection campaign on data and
technology Tim Murtagh is president
Trump's campaign spokesman and we knew
that we were better equipped to move to
an all virtual setting than anybody else
and so we did that in a matter of 24
hours and all of the things that we
would normally do as a campaign by and
large we're now doing we're now doing
online we have made approaching 20
million phone calls to voters across the
country in key states since we've been
since march 13th that is since since we
went all virtual and we've launched
online programming our unique online
programming seven nights a week and we
reach each one of those broadcasts has
achieved 1 million unique viewers at
least and some of them have actually
exceeded 2 million unique viewers and so
while these are unusual circumstances
there's no question that the president's
campaign is moving forward full steam
ahead and I would say we're even more
now than we were before we went into
this this all virtual setting
interesting yep but you and I both know
that the the signature campaign moment
for President Trump is really one of
those rallies right I mean those are
those were key in 2016 and I'm just
wondering how is it without the rally I
mean I imagine it's helpful at least it
is on TV every day but the the rally is
such a thing well Americans want to see
that their president is out front and
leading and in command of a situation
when we're facing a natural national
crisis and that's exactly what the
president is doing he's got two very big
responsibilities right now one is to
protect the health and safety of the
American people and the other is to
safeguard the economy and Americans can
see him he's been very visible in doing
those things and I think the people are
responding to that as far as the rallies
go you know they have been a great
source of energizing the the president's
supporters and attracting new supporters
those who were not with him in 2016 but
are now now coming into the fold and the
president is determined that we'll get
back out on the campaign trail and have
those rallies again when when it is safe
to do so because it is it's very
important for him to be able to be
talking to the American people heading
into the election but right now he's got
a very important job to do and that's
what he's doing
do you see a rally happening in this you
know before November like a real rally
with thousands of people together in the
same space yeah the president the
president is very optimistic that we'll
be able to do that and we're preparing
for the for the eventualities that we
will you know the president is obviously
in touch with the medical professionals
dr. Burks and dr. Falchi every single
day and is briefing the American people
as to what the country's progress is
towards that but we know look the the
coronavirus crisis will pass we know it
will pass in America and we'll America
will come through this stronger than
before and we have every confidence that
we will be back out on the campaign
trail and holding those rallies yes
during the last campaign immigration was
central to the president's message
now he's suspending immigration to the
United States
for those seeking green cards why I mean
what I can tell you from the campaign's
perspective is that this just fits in
line with exactly what we were just
talking about that the president has two
very important responsibilities one is
to protect the health and safety of the
American people and two is to safeguard
the economy and this halting of
immigration during the coronavirus
crisis addresses both of those
responsibilities first of all it
protects the jobs of Americans we know
that with increased competition if
you're introducing more and more
competitors for jobs in America
particularly at a time when you have
more than 20 million people who have
recently filed for unemployment
introducing competition for those scarce
jobs will only hurt American citizens
and legal residents and it will also
have the effect of driving down wages we
also know that it greatly impacts the
black communities and Latino communities
across the country so the president is
fulfilling his America first philosophy
by protecting the jobs of Americans and
secondly it just makes common sense that
in a time like this when the entire
world is facing this pandemic that we
don't want to open up the possibility
that even more people will come to this
country already infected with the virus
the president had a bump in his approval
rating right around I think it was like
late March early April but it seems to
have disappeared now that the
disapproval rating is up what do you
think happened there and as you know
that I'm sure the campaign looks at
numbers like that and you know wants to
effort getting that number back up and
what what do you think that's about and
how do you do that you can't live or die
with public polls there's no there's no
question of that and I think that polls
have been routinely and regularly wrong
about President Trump so when those
things happen it we don't really regard
that with with much concern we know what
we see internally and and that is that
people are responding to the president's
leadership in this right now Americans
can see their president on stage in
front of the cameras with the medical
professionals of the coronavirus task
force updating the Americans on what the
government has done and is doing to
protect them in this is this great
worldwide crisis and people are
responding to that and I think as we
move forward in the in the electoral
process you know Joe
has had some say the benefit of staying
out of the public eye and he's been
desperately searching for relevance and
trying to find some way to find a role
for himself during this this period of
time here and there really isn't any
place for him to have a role and there's
no relevance for him I think as we move
forward in the campaign and you begin to
see remember that Joe Biden has only
just now become the apparent opponent of
President Trump and he hasn't even yet
begun to be defined and so there are six
months to go with a few days extra six
months and some change left to go in
this campaign and we haven't even begun
to define Joe Biden yet and believe me
when that happens you'll see some
radical changes in those numbers the
president has mentioned repeatedly how
great the economy is I mean really over
the past three and a half years we've
been hearing that but what is the
strategy if some states are slower to
reopen than others and the economy just
is not where it was come November how do
you address that well there's there's I
think we talked about exactly how the
economy was it was under it was under
President Trump that the economy reached
unprecedented heights in the first place
it was under his policies and through
his leadership that we had an economy
that really no one alive on earth had
ever seen one had never seen one as
strong as it was and it was artificially
interrupted by the coronavirus there is
no question of that it was an outside
force that hit this economy President
Trump is the one who built it up to such
Heights in the first place and he will
do it a second time that's the argument
they were we will make but the campaign
Tim is is definitely going to face
questions about how all of this was
handled right there's gonna be a lot of
looking backwards on 2020 especially
when it's time to debate and I know the
president said last week you know what
was I supposed to do shut down the
country with no deaths having happened
that was his response when asked you
know if we didn't use the time he bought
us properly after shutting out flights
from Wuhan
you know but could we have been
following you know South Korea's lead
with like testing and social distancing
and contact tracing you know especially
since the president's own trained
adviser Peter Navarro warned about the
risk from the virus in late January
couldn't we have done some other things
I mean those are gonna be questions that
the campaign is gonna be asked first of
all the Peter Navarro
wrote that memo on the the president on
the very same day created and appointed
that coronavirus taskforce that all
Americans are now very familiar with
that's the that's the doctor Falchi dr.
Burke's group was now headed by the vice
president and the president also as you
know limited travel from China on
January 31st that at the time was called
xenophobic and and reactionary by Joe
Biden and we had endless numbers of news
stories written about it about how this
all this was going to upset diplomatic
relations and it was an overreaction
from the Trump campaign and the CBS ran
a story that they were worried that this
was going to damage our relationship
with China and the Trump administration
had gone too far and so now here we are
some two months later and people are
looking back and trying to reinvent
history and pretend that that wasn't
early enough when in fact when it
happened people were saying that it was
an overreaction well I want to ask about
the campaign and China specifically
because the president talked a lot about
China you know the last time around in
2015 and 2016 and we've heard him talk a
lot about China really throughout his
presidency specifically when it comes to
of course the the trade deal but even
while talking about his friendship with
President Xi he has accused them of
stealing our intellectual property which
we know is a very real thing at
manipulating their currency I'm
wondering now there were at this sort of
new place right with with China after
this virus and the President himself has
questioned China's numbers where does
the campaign sort of go with China now
does the president come out and say look
we now really need to bring
manufacturing back you know I was right
all along about you know about moving
manufacturing away from foreign
countries where where do things sort of
shift now with our relationship with
China certainly the president has always
been in favor of bringing the
manufacturing jobs back to our shores
and look if you go back to the campaign
in 2015 and 16 president Trump said oh I
don't want to say conservatively 10,000
times he said that he was going to stand
up to China if he became president and
you know looking back over American
history over the last many decades
everybody who has run for president
has run and campaigned on the the
promise that they would stand up to
China but no one ever did until Donald
Trump came along and then I don't know
why anyone was ever shocked about it but
when he became president and he actually
put into action his policies to get
tough on China on trade issues everyone
was shocked and the Democrats all said
oh you can't do this this is reckless
well it worked it got China to the
negotiating table and they have the
Phase one deal in place there's no
question of that
Trump policies work because they were
stealing to China had been ripping us
off and robbing Americans blind for
decades and the president brought them
to the table and got them to talk they
were they're gone they're gone they're
not ripping Americans off anymore like
they were Tim Murtagh thank you so much
for your time you bet thank you any time
[Music]
this is a be warned a sec with your Fox
News commentary
coming up despite the fact that social
distancing mandates have brought our
economy to a screeching halt and cause
an immeasurable amount of anxiety
millions of Americans continue to stay
at home because they believe they are
saving lives by slowing the spread of
coronavirus the sacrifice is being asked
of us have been largely based on models
that projected millions of cases at
horrifying death tolls however there are
some out there who say some states
shelter-in-place orders were inspired by
bad data
Alex Berenson is a prominent skeptic as
the coronavirus locked down and his
twitter feed
has become a repository of
unconventional wisdom about this and to
those who may not know him he's a former
New York Times reporter a successful
thriller writer and a man who wrote a
book and opposed to the conventional
wisdom that marijuana is safe and should
be legalized and until this global
crisis began if you looked at his
Twitter feed it was mostly about that
issue but then somewhere along the way
it began to tweet about the covert 19
outbreak and at first like many out
there Alex's tweets tended to reflect
alarm over the virus but then something
changed the first thing that happened
was I realized what the actual mortality
rates looked like by age so in other
words no one is saying that that SARS
Cove - isn't real that's not a real
virus that it doesn't kill lots of
people
but the question
is why is it that nearly all the people
it affects the most seem to be over 70
and many many of those seem to be over
80 and 90 and so that raises the
question whether some people are dying
with rather than of this and secondly if
there are things that we could do that
might protect those people rather than
you know shutting down all society and
causing massive economic harm massive
societal harm by the time about it by
the time you begin to express skepticism
about this we had full lockdown that
we're now experiencing really hadn't
begun that's that's right so what was it
prompted your skepticism that this
threat was being overrated was simply
the fact that it was distributed within
the population and to certain segments
well apparently not much elsewhere or
what I would say that was the first
question that you know this doesn't
really look like the Spanish flu Spanish
flu flu killed you know tons of children
tons of young adults it was very very
dangerous across the board this didn't
look like that to me but I would say the
first thing that when my real radar
really went off as a journalist was
March 25th Niall Ferguson who was the
author of the you know lead author of
the the seminal paper the imperial
college paper that said two million
Americans might die if we did nothing
about this gave testimony in Britain
where he reduced his his estimate for
the number of people who would die from
500,000 to 20,000 now now the 500,000
number assumed no mitigation efforts at
all in Britain okay but but the paper
came out on March 16th and in that paper
it says that even with reasonable
mitigation efforts the quarter of a
million people will die and a week later
nine days later he testified to the
British government that the most likely
number was 20,000 and I thought to
myself how on earth did we get from
250,000 to 20,000 in a matter of days
and I pointed this out and it was the
first thing that really grab people's
attention Elon Musk retweeted it other
you know major people retweeted it and
all the some I was in the middle of this
and I have been ever since and
since then it has been clear over and
over again that the models are just
completely wrong and they've completely
overstated the hospitalizations and the
ICU needs of this and 20 you stay to the
right what do you say to those who say
well you know models are models doctor
pouchy has said that he's always
skeptical of models and that you know
they they do the best they can with the
available data and as data becomes more
plentiful they update models and that's
a normal process and that's really just
what happened to here what's your that's
fine like the models were wrong I think
we can all agree about that what I don't
like is when people say oh the models
didn't account for lockdowns that's not
true the University of Washington model
explicitly accounted for lock cuts so
here's the question Britain if we want
to say okay the models were wrong back
in mid-march back in late March when we
did all this incredibly draconian stuff
okay well now we have more data we have
better data this doesn't look as
dangerous as it was it looks
significantly less dangerous it's clear
that the hospitals in the United States
are not being overrun with this that if
anything hospitals are emptier than they
were a month ago and under severe
financial strain so if the models were
wrong these guys did the best they could
we can all agree about that let's update
our policies let's not do what we were
doing a month ago and that to me is you
can't have it both ways if you want to
say okay the models were wrong why are
we doing stuff that's even more
draconian than we were a month ago the
argument is made I like that the reason
why these model numbers projections of
mortality caseload and so on have come
down so sharply is that the American
people have responded so willingly to
the mitigation efforts and it is their
having done so that accounts for the and
therefore this thing now looks for far
less dangerous than it did in the early
modeling you agree with that no I don't
there's increasing evidence so so we
need to sort of distinguish between
social distancing voluntary moderate
social distancing and hard locked outs
and just last week a very very good
paper came out of Germany and this was
this is published by the official German
Public Health Institute so Germany you
know has had a pretty aggressive testing
program and they've had a relatively
contained epidemic what they found was
that the infection rate and others the
rate at which this spread seemed to peak
in late February early March and then
Germany had a couple of moderate social
distancing measures imposed and the any
infection rate went way down and by the
time they imposed the hard lockdown
which was March 23rd the infection rate
was already at about 1:00 meaning every
person was only giving it to one other
person meaning it wasn't really
spreading very fast it's very hard to
look nationally and internationally and
say there's any relationship between
hard lockdowns and what's happened with
the epidemic now let me ask you about
one other aspect of this and that is the
death rate I posted on Twitter some time
back in which I said it looked like the
death rate in New York was being
overstated and the response to that was
you got it exactly wrong that that it is
not being overstated it's almost
certainly being understated because lots
of people have died from this that we
didn't know had it or they didn't know
had it and therefore the the real death
rate must be larger than the official
date with death rate we have now do you
buy that so this is a really complicated
argument and it's complicated for three
reasons
two two I would say are real and one is
political okay the first reason is that
again because of who's dying with this
who you know who's dying with Slash of
it
that's a hard distinction to make if
you're a hospice patient and you get you
get the flu or you get the corona virus
and you die did your underlying disease
kill you or did the did the infection
kill you I mean I would say most people
would say that the underlying disease
kills you but there's a legitimate at
this point it seems that they're coding
the death of any
one who had the disease as having been
having having died from it that's right
just with it so that's and and you can
argue that either way but we are
definitely in the United States taking a
very aggressive stance okay
so reason one is there's a legitimate
medical argument about this reason two
is we we have decided in the u.s. to
code this way so but I would say again
that you can make the argument that
that's okay but then a third thing has
happened in some states especially
unfortunately it looks like again as
everything else in our society right now
this is a blue versus red state thing
some states have decided that you don't
even have to have a positive test but
basically it looks like almost anybody
who is aged and has any sort of feel
like or pneumonia like symptoms and dies
you know in the last month is gonna be
coded as a Cova death without a positive
test and and it's hard to know why why
the states would do that except to try
to get the death counts up I mean I
don't understand what the sort of
medical rationale is and I haven't heard
a coherent one yeah that's a concern
isn't no let me ask this also yes so if
you were making policy here for going
forward what would you recommend so a
couple of things first of all I reopen
the schools as quickly as possible
one thing that is maddening to me is
that children are very very low risk
from this and other low risk of
infection or simply a low risk for
getting really sick it's interesting it
looks like they may really be at low
risk of infection too they're certainly
at low risk of getting very sick
much less dying if you look at all the
data worldwide and it's not just
children it's young adults too it looks
to me like more people over the age of
100 have died from kovat than under the
age of 30 it's so how would you what
measures would you recommend if you
reopen the schools for protecting adults
teachers you don't really have to worry
that much about protecting adults from
children there's evidence that
children's viral
loads are so low this is not the flu in
this case children actually get it from
adults rather than the other way around
so look if there if there are teachers
who have severe comorbidities who don't
want to come in for a while you know
maybe maybe you have more limited
schooling until we figure some of that
out but but the idea that we are denying
children and education and in some cases
we're sticking children at home with
abusive or drug-using parents and they
can't be seen by any other adults right
now that that is disgusting to me
because because children are not at risk
here they are effectively not at risk
and and anybody who wants to tell me I'm
wrong
let's look at the numbers together the
second thing I would do is I'd look at
in states where hospitals are not under
pressure and that's basically every
state now except New York I would very
quickly try to move to a phased
reopening so you so you first thing is
retail or I'm sorry first things offices
because there's again there's very very
little evidence of transmission outside
the home outside public transportation
and to a you know to those are the two
main vectors and oh here's the second
thing I would do right now is I'd reopen
all the parks and all the beaches and
everything else there's essentially no
evidence of significant transmission
through outdoor activities and it's
really unfair to people to do that to
them so you know you maybe wait a couple
of days if that opens stores and then
they you know then you then the next
thing is hospitality right bars and
restaurants and maybe you want to see if
there's any evidence of pressure on
hospitals you open those in it you know
in a week or two and then mass events
are gonna be the last thing that that
happened I mean would you recommend
continued social distancing I think
people are gonna do that on their own
and I think people want to wear masks
they can wear masks certainly if they're
you know if you're in a crowded subway
or something like that that makes sense
I don't I don't think there's super
strong evidence that masks make a big
difference but if it makes people more
comfortable it's a it's a good thing to
do oh and I the other thing I do
immediately and it looks like we are
trying to do this and it should have
happened three weeks ago is antibody
testing let's figure out how many people
have been infected with this thing
so we can figure out what the fatality
rate really is look you know you've got
doctors ouchy and Burks who look I'm not
an expert in this area this is not my
there's not my lane but I hear their
presentations are fun to be serious
qualified articulate able and they're on
board of this so they don't seem do yet
be having made any kind of a turn and
recognition of the data you cite what's
up is that in your view I don't I don't
know why that is there are very good
epidemiologist now speaking out on the
other side most notably a Swedish
epidemiologist who who ran you know
Sweden's Public Health Department for
for a number of years and and thinks the
lockdowns are a huge mistake he actually
gave a very good interview a couple of
days ago where he went I talked about
this in detail I'm not a conspiracy
theorist okay you know I don't think
this is like this is all part of plan to
you know to make a green come down yeah
I although obviously there are people in
the media who don't like her but here's
what I think when people take a public
position that causes massive massive
massive economic and societal disruption
it's gonna be hard to get them to
acknowledge that position was wrong or
even that even that it can be changed
right now in the light of new data
Alex Berenson journalist and author
thank you for your time thanks for us
it's the Perino and steyr Walt I'll tell
you what podcast Dana Perino of the five
and FoxNews political editor Christina
all dissect the ins and outs of national
politics subscribe and listen now by
going to fox news podcasts dot-com Radin
review the fox news rundown on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen it's
time for your fox news commentary
hornacek what's on your mind
so everyone is talking about exercises
you can do at home to stay fit during
this uncertain time but while our bodies
can be affected by eating excessive
amounts not moving
drinking alcohol etc I was thinking
about what being in quarantine does to
our brain the brain is one of the most
powerful organs in the body and it needs
stimulation to stay sharp in fact the
human brain can generate up to 23 watts
of power which is enough energy to light
a light bulb so if you're in New York
and you lose power just hook something
up to your brain you're good to go so
the human brain is pretty darn important
and needs exercise just like the rest of
our body something we cannot overlook
while social distancing that being said
there are two things I wanted to mention
to help with cognitive function posture
and meditation I just found out there
are these classes online you can take
through a program called master class I
personally have a propensity for
learning about the human brain and I
really wanted to share something about
posture and cognitive function think
about this a lot of us are home all day
long and for a large part of the day
that means sitting on couches bent over
laptops phones and other devices in one
of my online classes through master
class there was a very intelligent
speaker by the name of Christopher ng's
who gave a lecture called better posture
for better brain performance so
everything I'm about to say should be
credited to her dr. Byrnes shared that
with the evolution of upright posture
the human brain tripled in size and
functional capability when you think
about what our posture looks like one
more texting scrolling through Instagram
etc
our shoulders are rolled inward in our
neck is forward that posture affects our
reticular activating system which is the
part of our brainstem that sends the
information up to our brain that keeps
us awake and alert this is where dr.
burns made the perceptive connection
between posture and brain performance if
your posture wakes up your brain you can
imagine why we experience brain fog and
lower cognition when we are hunched over
a device for too long my point in going
through all of this is that while a lot
of us presumably are focused on the
exercise of our bodies admittedly me
included we should be taking the time
out of our day to pay attention to our
brain one easy thing to do is work on
your posture the other is meditation
it's been discovered that meditation can
change certain brain regions like the
medial prefrontal cortex and the
amygdala both of which are linked to
feeling down according to Harvard health
scientists have shown that the medial
prefrontal cortex becomes hyperactive
and people who are depressed the
amygdala also known as the fear center
is also linked with depression because
the adrenal glands release the stress
hormone cortisol in response to
perceived danger or fear those two brain
regions then play off of each other to
cause depression but Harvard Health says
that research found meditation helps
break that connection between those two
brain regions so while you're doing your
push-ups lunges down the hallway planks
and other at-home exercises may be
consider the long-term health of your
brain and add in a little meditation and
good posture Quarantine is the perfect
time to do it i'm abby hornacek check
out my podcast getting schooled and a
brand new season of parked out now on
Fox Nation
you've been listening to the FoxNews
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com love Fox News
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust and
click the FoxNews rundown playlist for
the latest episodes